scp-096 vs scp-3521  we know that looking at the shy guy's  face is enough to drive him bananas but  can a chaotic deluge of bananas from  within finally kill the monster  scp-096 has proven to be almost  unstoppable thanks to its indestructible  skeleton the creature has been almost  completely destroyed in the past and  still been able to pull itself back from  the brink with heightened regeneration  scp-3521 is a pill that causes truly  deranged quantities of bananas to appear  inside the victim's stomach killing them  with either ionizing radiation from the  potassium or massive bodily trauma from  all the bananas though personally we  think 096 could still survive even if  its stomach and torso burst open spewing  bananas everywhere it would still likely  regenerate once the banana onslaught was  done